مرحبًا هذه ماريا ديفا من خاركيف
أوكرانيا اليوم هو التاسع من مارس
وأنا أقف في الساحة السماوية رقم 100
في خاركيف والتي سميت على اسم
مئات المواطنين الأوكرانيين الذين ماتوا من
أجل الحرية والمستقبل الأوكراني
في الاتحاد الأوروبي في عام 2014 في الميدان
مربع في كييف والآن تم تدمير هذه الساحة هنا
في خاركيف بالكامل
بسبب القصف الروسي
هنا هو المبنى التاريخي الذي تم بناؤه
في بداية القرن العشرين
وهنا توجد محكمة الاستئناف
وفي جميع أنحاء المنطقة سترى المنطقة
السكنية  المباني ، المباني متعددة الطوابق
التي تم
تدميرها الآن ، ولكي تفهم مدى
صعوبة الانفجار ومدى صعوبة
سقوط الصاروخ ،
يمكنك أن ترى هنا
حفرة الصاروخ الذي أصاب هذه المنطقة
ولم يكن الوحيد لأنه
هناك سترى
المباني تعرضت أيضًا للقصف بالصواريخ الروسية